pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux aujourd'hui même si c'est
la pleine saison
je ne vais pas vous parler de la dinde
aux marrons ou de la bûche mais des cars
dont vous connaissez
ils sont plus faciles à trouver en
conserve que ferait sur le marché ce
proche parent de l'artichaut est cultivé
sur le pourtour méditerranéen depuis au
moins 2001 il fait partie de ce qu'on
appelle les légumes anciens
un peu oublié quoique en provence et
dans la vallée du rhône les cardons sont
toujours consommer surtout en période de
fêtes
autrefois il faisait systématiquement
partie du souper du 24 décembre et
prépare l organisme à l'abondance de
nourriture
il faut dire que pour cela le cardon
possède plusieurs atouts
d'abord il est riche en fibres qui
aident à la digestion et à réguler
l'absorption de graisses et de sucre
ensuite il contient de la cie narines un
composés polyphénoliques antioxydants je
sais c'est pas facile à digérer
je parle du terme pas de légumes c'est
lui qui donne un goût amer mais qui a
aussi des propriétés dépuratives très
utile pour le foie en période de fête
car pour bien faire les choses comme on
les faisait en provence le soir de noël
ce plat doit être accompagnée de six
autres légumes et poissons et de treize
desserts bon froid c'est pas terrible
mais jour avec un peu de moelle osseuse
c'est délicieux comme il n'y a pas de
viande on parle toujours de repas m
allez à bientôt bon réveillon et joyeux
noël si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]